well we've come a long way from this and
this the Invisible Man I can safely say
is the best version by far and the
absolute kick in the ass Universal needs
to resuscitate its dark universe
franchise remember the mummy in this
video we're gonna take a deep dive into
its twist endings as well as some
theories as to who was really under that
suit now most of you who follow my
channel know I usually do films that
aren't in theaters and that's partly
because I don't have the footage to work
with I've never heard of The Shard but I
just had to cover this film ASAP so bear
with me as I try to cobble what Clips I
can find
we start with Cecilia Cass a woman so
emotionally and physically abused by her
millionaire Tech boyfriend Adrian that
she decides to leave him in the middle
of the night he is so controlling that
the first shot we see of her is with his
arm physically around her waist in order
to make her escape she has to resort to
drugging him with diazepam she has to
delete the security cameras and climb
over a giant concrete wall which
surrounds his estate her escape isn't as
smooth as she planned when her dog Zeus
bumps into Adrian's car setting off the
alarm and just as she's about to make
her get away with the help of her sister
Emily
Adrian smashes through the car window
but isn't able to stop them actions
always speak louder than words when it
comes to characters and if a guy is
willing to literally smash his fist
through a car window you know he's not
to be [ __ ] with but unbeknownst to
Cecilia she drops the pill bottle
something that will come to haunt her
later on and for the next two weeks
Cecilia lives in total fear shacking up
with her cop friend James and too scared
to venture out beyond the front yard
although free she is still imprisoned by
the thought of him it isn't until she
receives a mysterious letter from
Adrian's brother informing her of his
suicide that things start to finally
look up and not only that he's entrusted
her with $100,000 a month for the next
four years as a beneficiary of his will
but here's where things start to get a
little weird over the course of the next
few days Cecilia experiences some odd
occurrences such as the fire during
breakfast and the footprints on the
sheet
as James says to her when she tells him
what she saw Adrienne will continue to
haunt you if you let him but where
things really take a turn is during her
job interview when halfway through the
meeting she faints only to find out that
the blood results showed that she had
diazepam in her system and at the same
time when she gets the call from her
doctor that same diazepam pill bottle
the one she used on Adrienne is found in
her washroom now if you pay close
attention in the scene there's also a
big clue that foreshadows Cecilia's
pregnancy after the doctor informs her
of the diazepam Cecilia puts down the
phone to look at the pill bottle but you
can still make out the doctor in the
background telling her to come in
because there's an important matter they
should discuss in person
Cecilia goes back to Adrian's brother
Tom the same one who disclosed the info
about the will and she tells him that
Adrian isn't dead he's invisible but
they just kind of look at her like she's
crazy and Tamir tells her that Adrian's
strength was able to find people's true
weakness to get into their heads and
that's exactly what he's doing to
Cecilia even in death Cecilia's biggest
weakness is her love for her friends and
family
something the invisible man begins to
exploit in the second act first by using
Cecilia's email to send a vicious letter
to her sister wishing her dead and the
second by punching James's daughter
Sydney and making her believe it was
Cecilia who did it by calling Adrienne's
cell Cecilia finds out that he's been
hiding in the Attic I mean that's where
I chill if I were an invisible man and
it's here she receives a very important
text message that will pertain to the
ending it says the word surprise but
we'll get to that in a bit on her way
down from the Attic she senses him there
and throws a bucket of paint which
actually is a great cool jump scare and
damn James is gonna be super pissed when
he finds this mess coming home and what
happens next is one of my favorite
scenes in the film as Cecilia tries to
fend off the Invisible Man and what
makes it so visceral is that it actually
feels like she's fighting an invisible
man unlike a lot of other films where it
just looks like the actor is fighting
air this is in part to having an actual
actor in a green suit play the attacker
so when Cecilia is hitting him it's
actually hitting someone the hits feel
like they're actually landing and not
just stopping in midair
cecilia manages to escape and calls a
lift someplace very far away Adrian's
home to look for proof that she's not
crazy one of the things I love about her
return is that all the furniture has
been covered up in linen so you're never
quite sure what could pop out and get
her it makes for a very uneasy sequence
in the basement we find Adrian's lab he
was the founder of a company called
optics which specialised in optical tech
it's here Cecilia finds the suit that
allows them to be invisible whereas
previous incarnations of the Invisible
Man were more biological in nature the
20/20 version is more grounded in
reality with writer director Leigh
Whannell actually telling reporters that
during his research on the project this
type of suit is theoretically possible
it's also interesting to note that a
suit that manipulates light in order to
achieve invisibility was created by a
man who uses manipulation to control
Cecilia the light of his life Cecilia
takes the suit and hides it in the same
hidden compartment she used for her
initial escape when she is once again
attacked by Adrian and Adrian is pretty
bad at this whole attack a defenseless
woman thing as Cecilia is once again
able to make it out venturing back to
the city to tell her sister what she saw
and just as she's about to tell Emily
about the hidden invisibility suit
Adrian slices her throat in the middle
of a crowded restaurant putting the
knife in Cecilia's hand framed for her
own sister's murder not to mention the
incriminating email Adrian sent a few
days ago posing as her saying that she
wanted a killer Cecilia is sent to a
psych ward it's he or she finds out that
she's pregnant with Adrian's child but
how is that possible
she told Emily and Tom earlier in the
film that she despised Adrian so much
she secretly was taking birth control
it's only when she's visited by Tom that
she gets her answer and we get one of
the first big twists of the film Tom
tells her that she's cut off from the
money but there is a way out for her if
she agrees to have the baby and get back
together with Adrian a new life can be
given to her Tom and Adrian are working
together in an elaborate plan in fact
tom says adrian knew about the birth
control and switched out her pills but
even more creepy is the timeline here
it's pretty muddy the nurse said she's
only about a
along in the pregnancy and we aren't
quite sure how much time has passed and
she last slept with Adrienne but we know
it's been at least several weeks meaning
that it's possible she was assaulted by
Adrienne during her time at James's when
she was drugged we already know that she
was drugged once before her job
interview
Cecilia of course says no by throwing
away Tom's legal papers and uses the
opportunity to steal one of his pens a
pencil a turista faked her suicide in an
attempt to reveal Adrienne you see the
only thing Adrian wants more than to be
with Cecilia is for him to have a child
and he won't let Cecilia get in the way
of that Adrian does stop her from
cutting herself but the commotion alerts
a pack of guards who are systematically
destroyed by the Invisible Man although
his suit does get damaged creating some
extra terrifying effects where he goes
in and out of visibility there's a
cat-and-mouse chase in the hospital
parking lot where Adrian now that he
can't harm Cecilia who is with child
boughs to go after though she loves if
she doesn't bend to his will he escapes
and Cecilia follows in pursuit calling
James knowing that Adrian will have
Sydney on his list of victims
James arrives back home gun drawn and
attempts to save his daughter but the
Invisible Man is just too damned
invisible it takes Cecilia coming in
with a fire extinguisher and a pistol to
finally put Adrian down or so we think
in the second major twist of the movie
it's revealed that it's not a treant
under that suit but Tom his brother it's
explained to Cecilia that Adrian was
found locked in his own basement and was
apparently tied up and held there by Tom
while Tom perpetrated all these crimes
but Cecilia isn't buying it although
Cecilia's innocents have now been proven
she still thinks it was Adrian who was
behind everything that tom was
manipulated by Adrian to go in wearing
that suit he essentially threw his
brother under the bus so Cecilia makes a
last-ditch effort to get Adrian to
confess she goes to his place for dinner
wearing a wire with James listening on
the other end not to mention she knows
where all the security cameras are in
the house which will come in handy later
she tries to get Adrian to say he was
the one under the suit but he won't and
there are three subtle clues that do
point to his culpability first he tells
her that she wasn't crazy although
that's fairly ambiguous
thing can be interpreted several ways
second and more damning is his
purposeful use of the word surprise the
exact word he texted heard the Attic and
also said during one of his attacks but
the third and most damning clue is his
facial expression after she goes to
freshen up in the washroom the director
here holds on Adrien for an
uncomfortable amount of time as the
slightest smirk is held on Adrien almost
as if he's saying I've won but that
smirk is short-lived as several moments
later his throat is cut and he bleeds
out on the floor Cecelia having
retrieved the suit she hid in the closet
and using it to quickly grab Adrienne's
knife and slice his throat making it
look like he committed suicide this is
all knowingly captured on the security
camera which would prove it was a
suicide James comes rushing in hearing
the commotion and his stock by Cecelia
he sees the duffel bag with this suit
tucked in and agrees to let this all go
down as a suicide Cecilia the girl who
lived in fear and spent the first half
of the movie running away from Adrian
has become the opposite strong fearsome
and chases him down now some may argue
out there that maybe Adrien was innocent
and it was his brother all along but the
evidence against it is just too
overwhelming first we know Adrian is a
master manipulator insanely intelligent
and has the ability to get into people's
minds tom one-upping this master
manipulator just doesn't jive with what
we've been told about Adrian but more
importantly is what would be Tom's
motivation why would he take pictures of
Cecilia at night why would he haunt her
at every moment woman he barely knows
save for some awkward family parties the
more reasonable assessment is that
Adrian manipulated Tom just like he had
been doing his whole life how well we
simply don't know but let's also take
for example that if Adrian were innocent
then that throws into questions
Cecilia's murder of him casting the
ending in a far more grim light than it
already is
the Invisible Man is a great horror
thriller with plenty of twists and new
takes on an old classic that make it
seem fresh if Universal can take these
old monsters and creatures and create
new and interesting ways to tell those
stories there may be hope for the dark
universe yet I hope you enjoyed this
video please smash that like button and
subscribe
as I always have new content on the way
you can also follow me on Twitter at
things story whitey
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much